je suis dans le xviiie arrondissement de
paris devant la boulangerie au levain
d'antan pour rencontrer celle qui comme
tous les boulangers en ce moment on
connaît des problèmes a fortiori si
aussi bonjour savoir que si vous avez
mais l'augmentation du prix des matières
premières est quand même assez important
il voulait dire farine varenberg les
eaux les céréales tout augmente tout
remonte et du coup on va être obligé à
fortiori d'augmenter nos prix chose
qu'on s'était refusé à faire jusqu'à
maintenant on va plus répercuter les
prix sur la viennoiserie là où il ya
beaucoup de beurre là où il ya beaucoup
de travail et sur le prix des pains
spéciaux parce que vous avez peur que
des clients puissent vous boudez venir -
parce que de ça va c'est de plus en plus
cher alors je pense que c'est pas nous
bouder ils vont pas nous bouder ils vont
ils subissent comme nous l'augmentation
de tous donc un moment donné il va
falloir qu'ils fassent des choix est-ce
que de ce fait vous perdez du chiffre
d'affaires oui complètement là on a eu
sur sur le mois de décembre est le mois
de janvier qui sont normalement des mois
qui permettent de renflouer un peu les
caisses et d'avoir de la trésorerie
on a eu une perte de chiffre d'affaires
d'un peu plus de 10% donc si vous voulez
m'accompagner dans le fournil on va
parler un peu de tout ça on sera mieux
au chaud
[Musique]
je pense que ça va vous de plus
les matières premières qu on peut voir
ici elles ont augmenté en quelle
proportion la farine elle a augmenté
en proportion de plus ou moins 10% le
beurre il a augmenté de presque 40% il
ya plusieurs raisons à ça je pense
l'augmentation du prix du pétrole ou
tout ce qui est transporter les
spéculations liées à la farine liés au
blé mais là c'est tout d'un coup on fait
tous qui augmente d'un course et nos
matières premières c'est nos matières
avec l'acs lesquels on travaille tous
les jours on ne peut même pas s'en
passer donc on peut même pas les
remplacer nous il a fallu qu'on s'adapte
tout le temps et pour autant ben on est
un petit peu les les oublier
pour les gens qui ont déjà du mal à
payer le loyer à finir à finir le mois
c'est vrai qu'une augmentation d'une
baguette qui est un produit de base
c'est vraiment quelque chose de
compliqué et pour les patrons aussi pour
pour garder leurs employés avec tous les
prix qui augmentent mais du coup ça fait
une tension sur les salaires qui est qui
est compliqué à tenir aussi pauvre je
suis arrivé à un seuil d'inquiétude dont
du du fait que 20 tous les mois là on
est en train de réfléchir à comment
ne pas perdre trop d'argent et gagner un
petit peu pour
pour être tranquille pour pouvoir payer
nos salariés pour pouvoir payer nos
fournisseurs pour pouvoir payer les
charges pour pouvoir payer nos emprunts
et puis après ben pouvoir se payer soi
même
aujourd'hui vous avez dû augmenter mais
très peu de produits vous avez dû le
faire alors la baguette vous ne
toucherez pas on verra ça dans quelques
mois ce qu'elle a déjà augmenté ces
dernières années alors nous on l'a
augmentée il ya quelques années on est
resté à 1 euro 20 et on espère y rester
malheureusement je crois que si on doit
l'augmenter ben l'augmentera que pensez
vous de cette concurrence des grandes
surfaces avec leur fameuse baguette à 29
centimes d'euros ça pour moi c'est
inadmissible c'est inadmissible de
pouvoir se dire que un agriculteur un
céréalier
derrière cette vague est à 29 centimes
et payés au juste prix qu'un meunier est
payé au juste prix que le transporteur
est payé au juste prix et que le
boulanger derrière et payés au juste
prix 29 centimes
si ça marche pas donc c'est clairement
une sorte de diversion marketing en fait
pour attirer le client oui c'est pour
attirer le client certes mais derrière
les gens se posent la question mais
pourquoi vous votre baguette elle est à
1 euro 20 ben on n'est pas dans la même
catégorie en fait
alors c'est avec et de quoi auriez vous
besoin maintenant pour survivre que
votre activité se maintienne que les
prix cesse d'augmenter comme comme ils
sont en train d'augmenter que ça se
stabilise un petit peu on aurait besoin
d'un soutien de l'état on aura besoin
d'eux que tout fonctionne comme avant
que le restaurant fonctionne que les
français en consomment que les français
aient confiance en nous et qui que le
gouvernement ait dit arrête de nous de
nous taxer
constamment de toutes ces augmentations
de prix
toutes ces
toutous qui augmente d'un moment donné
ça va mettre en péril notre savoir faire